product not yet rated
hi i'm luke goldspink one of the
producers at team 17
and today i'm going to introduce you to
the dark fantasy medieval inspired
action rpg
thymesia launching steam for windows pc
later this year
thymizi is one of our team 17 indie
games label titles
and is being developed by our friends at
overwater studio in taiwan
set in a world of alchemy that's been
ravaged by an insidious plague
and populated by terrifying monsters
thymesia tells the story of corvus
a mysterious individual who's entrusted
with the task of curing the plague
as the quest unfolds corvus will
discover untold truths and secrets that
ultimately lead to a decision on how to
handle the plague
to vanquish the source of the
ever-spreading malevolence or let the
kingdom fall to its own hubris
the destiny of humanity is up to him
thyme easy is not for the faint of heart
the monsters plaguing the kingdom are
extremely
deadly and skilled in combat and many
have fallen to them
but luckily corvus is a new committed
battle
as the quest develops this half-human
half-raven would-be savior
must use every tool in his arsenal from
his uncanny agility
to dual wielding saber and dagger and
raptor like claws and feathers
inspired by macabre medieval acts of
bloodletting
practiced by plague doctors whenever
corvus deals damage to any enemy
they let out some of their energy hit
them with your chlorine time
and absorb the energy corvus can also
reeve the plague from the enemy
and use it across a range of
plague-powered weapons
such as a two-handed halberd pike that
unleashes high levels of damage
and a sight that delivers area effect
damage to enemies
give them a taste of their own medicine
this is the only way to survive this
desolate kingdom
[Music]
corvus combat ability can be further
enhanced and upgraded to thimesia's
talentery system
whether that's turning parrying into
defense unleashing longer and more
devastating combos
linking together different dodgers and a
whole lot more
these abilities when combined with the
plague weapons allows players to develop
it to suit their own style of play
or even adapt it as challengers of all
we'll share more of thymesia over the
coming weeks ahead of its launch later
this year
thanks for watching